moi je suis blanc un bon gros bateaux et
parmi les blancs je suis vraiment très
très blanc bien sûr que moi quand je
prends une photo la nuit avec le flash
jeu reflète la lumière
on dirait un panneau de circulation
parfois quand je fais une photo de moi
sur instagram et que je mets un filtre
je disparais de la photo bon c'est un
peu relou c'est à dire que moi on voit
mes veines à travers ma peau quand je
montre mon muscle on dirait un radio les
chinois voyagent suis blanc mais alors
quand je vois un texto gens ne voient le
smiley ours blancs celui qui le plus
blanc possible moi avec ma peau je
bronze jamais ou alors même si année je
bronze après des milliers d'heures
d'exposition au soleil ça soit à peine
[Musique]
maintenant j'en reviens j'ai été pendant
un mois sous le seuil des caraïbes comme
je crains à mort les rayons du soleil
quand je fais la piscine extérieure je
dois porter un t-shirt où je suis le
seul boulot ce qui fait ses longueurs
avec un tee shirt
mais l'organe se noya
enfin
les blagues entre communautés faut pas
trop en abuser
ça peut être un peu gênant moi en tant
que gros blancs aux yeux bleus j'ai
souvent droit alors poté blond aux yeux
bleus un arrière à quoi le nazi merci ça
avance un pad est associé à l'un des
mouvements les plus d'exterminateurs du
monde c'est vraiment flatteur
il ya des trucs qui vont moins bien aux
blancs c'est pas un renoi ou un métis
avec le crâne rasé
c'est tout un peu hip hop tu vois moi je
pourrai jamais alors le crâne rasé
c'est sur jean paul ii [ __ ] j'ai peur
pourtant cancer je passe cancer c'est un
nouveau style que je me suis donné
j'fais je suis un peu hip hop
même avec la chimiothérapie tu gardes
ton humour ça s'est vraiment bien ça
n'importe quoi c'est n'y a pas de
chimiothérapie et c'est mon nouveau
style objets profit des derniers jours
d'ailleurs à ce propos j'ai découvert un
truc plutôt flippant en allant chez le
dermato voilà moi j'ai un max de grains
de beauté partout comme beaucoup blanc
sauf que le terme at home a expliqué la
vraie nature en fête des grains de
beauté
bon bah norman jay comptez vous avez 2
341 grain de beauté 341 génial c'est ça
donc 341 me cancer est inoffensif
wen et qu'on disait ah ben moi je vais y
aller impression j'avais piscine
je vais aller nager évidemment avec un
t-shirt où les blancs on est aussi
parfois victime de clichés - comme ce
cliché qui dit que les blancs savent pas
danser c'est n'importe quoi
bon ok c'est vrai on sait pas très bien
dans celle surtout surtout moi c'est nul
c'est cliché c'est comme quand j'entends
dire les noirs sont des meilleurs coups
au liquide blanc n'importe quoi attends
moi je suis blanc je ne cache pas que
parfois je me suis fait un peu
complimenter si tu vois ce que je veux
dire
parce qu'ils sont entre autres
non merci moi j'ai la chance d'avoir pas
mal de potes issus de la diversité et
j'ai l'impression que certaines ethnies
qui sont quand même plus chaleureuse que
d'autres jeunes fois quand renault à
croiser un autre noir inconnu on dirait
que son mégapot depuis les années six
mois c'est ce mois ci à l'air de sané
ouais tout droit sur la gauche pas merci
atteinte assurance à ses lauréats temps
alors que quand un blanc croise un autre
blanc a connu c'est pas pareil
bonjour bonjour tu vas bien
on se tutoie direct en battant les
voisins depuis deux ans s'il vous plaît
à bien son troisième s'il vous plaît à
tanger mais bon voilà je suis blanc très
blanc et alors c'est comme ça bien des
personnes pour empêcher ce qui fait la
vie même pas les coups de soleil
monsieur ont créé derrière il ya plus de
soleil on sait jamais j ai tout le temps
à tous
par mon tableau des médailles ou sans
handicap et j'avais besoin
j'ai beau je suis dans ma bulle dans ma
bulle quoi pendant la bulle c'est un
album de diam's